مئات المشجعين همم في قاعه وسط الدار
البيضاء من سبع فيها جمهور من كازابلانكا
هذه هي المباريات هذه الدقائق صعبه همم
الجمهور هنا والمغاربه يحبسون انفاسهم وكل
العرب في انتظاره هدفي التعادل الامال
تبقى عريضه في ان يتمكن المنتخب المغربي
الذي يظهر همم جهدا كبيرا ومستمر في
الاداء بشكل جيد كما يلاحظ الجمهور في ان
يتمكن من تحقيق هدف التعادل ولا حكم ايضا
قبل همم تبدا المباريات الاجواء كانت
حماسيه وكانت هناك احتفالات والجميع ينتظر
الليله همم فوز المنتخب المغربي وهذه
الليله ستكون ليله استثنائيه هناك
استعدادات الاحتفالات اكبر واضخم في
كازابلانكا وفي كل مدن المغرب اذا ما تمكن
المنتخب المغربي من التجاوز الى الدور
النهائي
وبالتالي يكون اول منتخب عربي وافريقي يصل
الى نهائي كاس العالم الجمهور هنا يتفاعل
مع الجهد الذي يبذله الدفاع المنتخب
المغربي في صد الهجمات الفرنسيه ومع كل
هجمه مرتده وكل محاوله من المنتخب المغربي
لتسجيل هدف هذه هي الاجواء الان مع امل
كبير وتركب في انتظار هدف التعادل
ان شاء الله كما يامل الجمال